what do you say to people who just say
this is not a normal way of living
thank you very much
i'm catherine and this is my husband
wayne i'm wayne and welcome to freedom
coat
we live in a secluded cove
the only option we have to get here is
by water there are no road accesses
the water is our highway
everything that you see here
in our home is floating
we are tied to shore with lines we are
not anchored
we have our main living house
we have the dance floor
the lighthouse building
four greenhouses
as i started to grow the garden and make
it larger then we had to have more space
for that garden
everything's done with a hand saw and
hammer
no power tools i know every board and
nail by name
it's about 500 tons
a million pounds when i'm flowing
i've been building tree forts since i
was seven
and i said well dad i'm putting a tree
fort in the ocean do you ever get
seasick
no when i go to town i get land sick
the thing about living in clockwood
sound on the west coast of vancouver
island it's the richest biomass on earth
so the opportunity to fish for dinner is
big
and i just get in my canoe and paddle
out in 10 minutes i can catch a fish
but when it's windy and too too rough
out there i can lay on the couch and
fish out of the house
i was hoping to make a lot more money as
an artist
so subsistence living was our only
opportunity to have anything as artists
we could never buy real estate so we had
to make our own
it was a great opportunity to actually
move away from the city to see if we
could
prosper out here now 24 years later
we're still doing it
i can't imagine living any other way
i feel completely fulfilled
oh that's good
that's really nice
i'm working on it